ici nous sommes dans un site de
recherche et développement de
l'industrie pharmaceutique l'objectif
des scientifiques et des médecins du
site et de trouver de nouveaux
médicaments pour les patients
1800 personnes travaillent sur toutes
les étapes de recherche et de
développement des médicaments ce qui
fait que le site de Chilly-Mazarin est
l'un des plus importants au niveau
mondial pour Sanofi
nous travaillons sur la recherche
fondamentale la recherche qui est proche
du monde académique la recherche pour
les médicaments dans le domaine
cardiovasculaire dans le domaine des
maladies neurodégénératives Alzheimer
Parkinson et puis après la recherche
nous organisons sur le site la
coordination sur les études de clinique
les études de cliniques ça consiste à
pouvoir démontrer après au niveau
mondial chez les patients que nos
médicaments vont être efficaces avec un
minimum de risque pour les malades
ce qui est très important pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique pour la santé
des patients c'est de pouvoir suivre
l'efficacité et la sécurité des
médicaments ensuite quand ils sont sur
le marché c'est la pharmacovigilance et
de large équipe de pharmaco vigilance
travaille sur le site
donc nous sommes sur toute la chaîne de
la recherche au développement au
bénéfice des patients dans le monde
pour nous pour les équipes de
scientifiques et de médecins du site il
est dès essentiel de pouvoir être
connecté avec les meilleurs équipes au
niveau académique c'est ce que nous
trouvons et ce que nous allons trouver
avec les équipes de Paris Saclay dans
ses laboratoires nous avons des postdocs
des étudiants qui après leur thèse
viennent débuter leur activité dans le
domaine de la recherche en industrie et
également nous avons une pratique de
pouvoir accueillir des équipes
universitaires par exemple de Paris-Sud
ou bien de l'Université de Versailles
le centre de recherche existe depuis
1958 et les équipes dont je viens de
parler ont noué des collaborations avec
des équipes du plateau de Saclay mirsen
NeuroSpin le Labex l'ermite le CEA
autant de centres d'excellence qui vont
nous permettre de mieux rechercher et
développer nos médicaments